vous intéressez vous à la protection de
nature énormément comme beaucoup de
monde c'est maintenant tout le monde est
sensibilisé moi je suis beaucoup mais
pas plus pas plus que je crois que le
français moyen maintenant très
sensibilisée par ce qu'ils mangent de
pas ce qu'ils mangent tous les jours par
tous les problèmes dans la nature et
comme je le disais le président le
présent le commandant cousteau
il disait en dix ans le matin le mot de
cambronne du matin merde c'est pour ça
que vous devriez défilé dans les rues et
pas pour autre chose
et puis ouvrir les yeux au gouvernement
c'est pour ça qu'il faut des filets pour
ça mais on peut se battre dans la rue
la seule chose qui vaille la peine c'est
la nature